This next story is both really funny and
also really tragic because lots of people
get their so-called news from Sean Hannity
on Fox News last night on his program,
Sean Hannity sort of haphazardly and
indirectly admitted that he doesn't vet
the information that he gives out on the show.
Now, he was trying to make the case that he's
so independent that he doesn't check with
other people. He doesn't need anybody's
permission to say whatever the hell he wants
on his program. Nobody is telling him what
stories to cover and not to cover. But what he
actually ended up admitting is that he doesn't
even necessarily know whether what he's telling
you is accurate. He doesn't necessarily know
if what he's telling you is true, which is
actually not unique to Sean Hannity's program as
far as Fox opinion programs are concerned. But
I'm going to get back to that. And it relates
to a lawsuit involving Tucker Carlson from a few
months ago. But let's set it up. Here is a clip of
a defiant and principled Sean Hannity telling you
he might be giving you false information regularly
on his program. Take a look.
We in this hour, I am not told what to
say. I don't vet the information on this program
that I give out. We have always been independent,
follow our own path on this show that
that's not going to change for me ever.
If you thought that it might change, this will not
change ever, says Sean Hannity. Now, of course,
anybody who understands and pays attention to
Fox News with a critical eye knows this. I mean,
just in the past few months, Sean Hannity notably
promoted bogus coronavirus treatments and cures.
He promoted and regularly promotes voter fraud,
conspiracy theories related to the election,
including that Donald Trump won this state, that
state, the other state, none of which there's a
speck of evidence for. But the problem is that
lots of Hannity's viewers don't realize that
this is merely an opinion show and one we've now
learned, thanks to Sean Hannity admitting it. It's
one where Hannity doesn't even vet the things that
he puts out on the air. But here's what I want to
remind you. This is really the important thing
in an effort to sort of build an understanding
of media literacy. This is not actually unique to
Hannity. This is not about Sean Hannity. Persay,
back in September, we covered this on the bonus
show Fox News. His own lawyers said in court
that the audience shouldn't believe that what
Tucker Carlson says on his program is facts.
There was a case against Tucker Carlson for
slander in the southern district of New York. And
in the opinion from the judge, there were quotes
from Fox News, his lawyers made in the case. And
the defense that Fox News lawyers put forward
was that anyone who watches Tucker Carlson show
should just be able to tell from what they
referred to as the general tenor of the program
that Tucker Carlson is not, quote, stating actual
facts on his program and that what Tucker Carlson
is doing this is lawyers for Fox News saying
Tucker should not be held to that standard
because Tucker uses exaggeration and non literal
commentary. This is the evil genius of this. You
have an entire political movement in this country
that has been taught, molded and conditioned
to take their political agenda from Fox News.
If Fox News says council culture is the issue,
then that's the issue. And you spread it around to
Fox News says the issue is, you know, Trump really
won or whatever, that that becomes the issue.
And in particular, they get this agenda from
the nighttime opinion shows on Fox News, of
which, you know, we're including Sean Hannity,
Tucker Carlson, Laura Ingraham, Jeanine Pirro on
the weekends. You know, Lou Dobbs, I think is Fox
Business, Mark Levin, all of these people, we all
know that these are merely bogus opinion shows
that are meant to fire up and radicalize and anger
the base which works. And then you see Fox News
successfully set the agenda that pervades politics
around the country for the American right wing.
But when the rubber hits the road and these hosts
start getting sued for slander or they have other
legal issues because of false statements, they've
made the lawyers show up and they don't even
hesitate. They immediately go to anybody should be
able to tell. These are not facts being presented.
This is entertainment. It's not political
commentary. And it's it's actually what
Alex Jones's lawyers also argued in. I don't
remember if it was a some kind of libel or slander
suit or maybe his divorce proceedings, I don't
even remember. But his lawyers essentially said,
you can't you can't litigate anything that's
said on the show because it's it's entertainment.
It's just a character that Alex Jones is playing.
That's exactly the problem, though, which is that
Fox News's business model has been let's dress
up radical conspiracies and wild speculation
that would. Not normally be on national cable
TV, but let's produce it in a way that it looks
like real news and when you flip around and
importantly, Fox News on the cable dial often
is right next to actual news networks. People
flip around and they see it. And it's like, well,
looks like news. The anchors talk like this is
news. I guess this is news and people fall for
it. So where they say in the lawsuit defending the
defense against a lawsuit against Tucker Carlson,
when the Fox News lawyers say any viewer
should be able to tell this is not factual
news where we present facts, that's true. But
they're very business model has depended on
looking like real news so that when people
see it, they think they're watching news.
Part of it is a media literacy issue. It's
an education issue for sure. But part of
the problem is that Fox News is participating
in being deliberately confusing about exactly
what they are putting out. They blend the news
and opinion. We've talked about that before,
but they also present opinion shows as if they are
serious programs rather than mere entertainment.
And what it leads to is an audience that when they
don't get what they want on Fox, they end up being
radicalized over to networks like Newsmax and on.
And that's exactly what I want to talk about next